halo but hello congratulations his
services to have received the Nobel Prizes
present i am very touched little l
effect the small breasts my name is
Helen and I phone you from Novell
prince with orchids thank you very much
to have to give us some time
to push us to a few questions
oh yes yes you were or when you got
so the news of having here actually
the game makes the sword on the street in
done i was i was not expecting yes
I was in the street and emma flip
he warned me ahead of time your breasts
phone calls yes yes and that
I really like this at last but I was very
touched especially since I am moved
especially since I have a little son
Edward I hear it moved me ok again
and you said yes in the center of paris
in which laughs yes I was on the side of
was waiting or the garden side of the
luxembourg a super his peers and that wants
say what for you to receive the award
nobel what does it mean to you
listen to it first
one on the game takes not at all
to have this thing really it got me
much touched that the juries but that
made me a lot of smokers yes but has
stretched out his emotions hand to help you
are writing several years
why are you actually writing yes I have that
I started very early because I
in fact I lost it particular wheels
and I started very early at the age of
20 years old and so
yes it starts to do a lot in
my pace for me yes it was some
natural thing at the end of the game yes it's
one thing but since the beginning and
that she scree because you have
writes about twenty or thirty
books
there is some vacuum that you like
a lot to what means
several pounds of other facts because
that in fact I always had the impression
to describe a little bit the same book it's up to
say decree is already almost 45 years
yes I always had the impression
to write the same book is actually in
taking a bit of a continuous way
like that but it was always a
little the same book of the same and obviously
we are not quite happy with this
that have written because when we write
can never really be his reader
so all that is a bit confusing but the
only socialist impression and that
it was the same book as if
I stopped for them to take a
step but actually it's part of the
even the same book written for 45 years
but if we will tell the world that she is
this is the book we have to read
now the first of the calves as
now you had to have a package
in the world
yes, uh, we are always said more
I always feel like it's the
last book I write in fact and
is called how is it called hum
that the so that you do not lose yourself in
the neighborhood
for keith dean ethernet to 1 2 for that
you do not get lost they have like
someone who gives a concept everything for
that you do not get lost in the neighborhood
in fact it's the last deal to comes from
look
we are always a little
after we lose a little visibility of
motives but the last obviously this is
the one you still have a little bit of
all want more and you have to do the
party tonight with hunger and the big
family what are you going to do
yes finally yes does I yes I would like
to be spans yes with the family yes has
do you face yes with my little son you are
I make my reach must say that it
I am very moved by those who are
different countries
yes and you come in the month of December
here at stockhom we are it not
yes yes that a pure or with the big
family yes yes you have a great
family not because currently it's
just two girls can
now I do not have a big
family good bah thank you very much and again
I see congratulations refuge and to
soon and I hope and I think that
it's not too confusing what I could
the more I do not think at all not of the
thank you very much for your time and
I hope you have a good evening
and ten states are sincere of Sweden
and the nobel press
I am very touched thank you very much
see you soon Goodbye